we begin tonight with numbers huge
numbers virtually impossible to grasp a
budget deficit has surged to an all-time
high figures show the US budget deficit
has more than tripled since last year
the federal budget deficit for 2009 is a
record-setting 1.4 trillion dollars that
more than tripled the previous record
which had been set just in 2008 1.4
trillion dollars is a huge amount of
money and it helps to think about it in
terms of what all that dough could buy
it would pay for a year of tuition at
Sidwell Friends the private school that
Barack Obama's daughters attend for
every public school student in the
country between grades 1 through 12 it
would help keep John Murtha johnstown
Cambria County Airport up and running
until the year 930 5342 ad it would rent
representative Charlie wrangles eleven
hundred dollar a night vacation condo in
the Dominican Republic for 1.2 billion
nights 1.4 trillion dollars is enough to
give every man woman and child in
America a copy of the complete idiot's
guide to getting out of debt with
overnight delivery a year supply of Zola
a Vespa motor scooter and a voucher for
the maximum legal contribution to the
politician of their choice the Obama
administration has just released its
projected budget deficit for fiscal year
2010 the total another 1.4 trillion
dollars for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you